porque las aerolíneas de eeuu advierten
que la expansión de la red 5g podría
causar caos en los vuelos del país a
través de su representante airlines
programa de briqa pidieron al gobierno
suspender la implantación de esta
tecnología alrededor de las terminales
averías de ese país por esto por el tipo
de bandas de frecuencia que se utiliza
esta tecnología que entraría en
conflicto con los sistemas de seguridad
de las aeronaves y que tendrían
consecuencias catastróficas según ellos
también según las compañías los sistemas
actuales de los aviones quedarían
inutilizables los radio altímetros que
miden la distancia entre la aeronave y
el suelo así como los sistemas de datos
que ayudan a los aviones a aterrizar
serían estos los más afectados para ello
entonces quiero saludar en ese momento a
nuestro segundo invitado el es ricardo
del piano analista de transporte aéreo
también cientista político e historiador
director de contenido de aeronaves
puntocom gracias por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 ricardo
entonces le pregunto qué pasa con él a
red 5 hey por qué causa tanta
preocupación en eeuu europa no ha sido
acusado tales problemas y el despliegue
de esas redes en esa banda ha
transcurrido sin complicaciones le
preguntó entonces qué diferencia hay al
despliegue en europa del que hay en eeuu
principal buenos días a todo el equipo
de toda la audiencia el principal
problema que existe en eeuu y de lo que
se está manifestando es la intensidad
con el cual estamos de atrás mil antenas
transmisoras encima mente ubicados en
las cercanías de los aeropuertos lo que
estaría poniendo en riesgo o en un
posible riesgo es el tema de la
seguridad de ella sobre todo en fases
críticas como es una aproximación del
tipo en base a la performance que el rnp
o del tipo y ls que sobre todo en eeuu
que se ocupan muchos aeropuertos y
especialmente en aeropuertos de la
condición de meteorología adversa donde
se utilizan estos equipos que son
fundamentales para garantizar la
seguridad y un aterrizaje seguro es por
eso que la preocupación causa bastante
precisamente es la intensidad de las
transmisiones inalámbricas crear antena
5g ahora ricardo en el caso de eeuu que
se está haciendo al respecto para que no
entonces la seguridad de los aviones lo
que hay hecho eeuu es un acuerdo entre
las empresas de telecomunicaciones 600 y
verisón por el gobierno y las líneas a
ellas un compromiso del cual se reduce a
reducir por un periodo de seis meses la
intensidad de las antenas en un radio de
dos millas alrededor de un aeropuerto no
está especificado que exactamente qué
área que específica del aeropuerto baste
para reducirse entonces la política
existe también una incertidumbre al
respecto
y eso es lo que genera personas en seis
meses las empresas hablan de un acuerdo
voluntario pero además esto eso fue un
acuerdo climático ahora el gran
interrogante es qué va a pasar en estos
periodos con el cual se va a ver se va a
investigar el efecto de las
transmisiones 5g de las cercanías de los
aeropuertos y qué va a pasar después de
estos seis meses cuando la intensidad y
el nivel de intensidad de las
transmisiones sea muy cercano al que
utiliza los radio altímetros del equipo
de las aeronaves es hay una
incertidumbre y lo que vemos es
precisamente lo que preocupa a la
industria no es lo que pase ahora sino
lo que va a pasar más adelante es por
eso que mucho
líneas aéreas han sugerido suspender o
postergar la entrada del 5g ahora
también hay acusaciones de lado y lado
porque haití y verizon atribuyeron gran
parte de la culpa a la administración
federal de aviación de eeuu pero quien
realmente tendría la razón en este
estévez conflicto por esta acusación es
mejor dicho bueno sin duda es esto de
nuevo un nuevo desafío para la industria
aérea dijeron que hay que hacer un mea
culpa la historia tiene que ser capaz de
hacer un mea culpa porque estas
decisiones no bien no se toman
imprevistos o cuando uno establece una
instaura nueva tecnología así como lo
eran algunos planifica entonces que la
industria aérea
la autoridad administración general de
aviación la epea no haya puesto en la
advertencia han años antes sobre todo de
esta entrada en vigencia y haya
informado a la industria de las posibles
consecuencias que esto podría traer
demuestra que hay una reacción tardía al
respecto y se está trabajando sobre la
marcha obviamente que para el industrial
aviación esto no es favorable sobre todo
después de dos años de afecciones
significativas en términos con la
pandemia hoy tenemos el efecto micro has
estado muchas cancelaciones
hasta el 5 g en un periodo de invierno
hemisferio nosotros no sabemos que las
cancelaciones de vuelos son habituales
por medio de nuestras berza y
precisamente meteorología adversa es
cuando estos son los equipos como un
aterrizaje por instrumentos uniese mp
sólo más utilizado previamente por la
menor visibilidad que hay en los
aeropuertos pues es fundamental al
evitar ya esto no llega en un buen
momento y la volumen una posición muy
desfavorable el momento de anticipar
crisis
yo creo que la gran lección o el gran
desafío que tiene y para qué bueno cómo
solucionamos este este inconveniente
riccardo como esto afectaría el tráfico
aéreo teniendo en cuenta que en muchos
aeropuertos estarían afectados ya pues
hemos escuchado también noticias de que
en eeuu o varias aerolíneas han desviado
sus vuelos en aeropuertos donde esta red
no esté tan cercana a la pista de
aterrizaje
exactamente cómo afecta pero yo creo que
podría haber se espera que haya nuevas
ciertas cancelaciones de esta ayer en un
comunicado donde va a recordar que
reconoce precisamente que van a haber
cancelaciones de vuelos
por el tema de 5g porque hay que
recordar es aquí se está combinando
varios factores una está el tema de 5g
otro está el invierno del hemisferio
norte otro establece las consecuencias
que teniendo omicron en las
cancelaciones de vuelos bueno
precisamente con los contagios las
tripulaciones entonces se ha generado
una cadena de sucesos que quiere que
desemboca en el mismo hecho y está
provocando que se queden posibles
cancelaciones y eso lamentablemente los
viajeros los usuarios tienen poco margen
de acción básicamente lo único que hay
que estar atentos a las informaciones de
la compañía de salida que brindan que la
información que se va publicando en el
día a día o las actuaciones que reciban
los viajeros precisamente es el escaso
margen que tienen de acción y
básicamente eso pues afortunadamente los
foros pop hace que los vuelos afectados
por temas exclusivamente el 5g ha sido
muy poco fueron 240 el día del primer
día de lanzamiento precisamente yo
estuve en un avión en varios aeropuertos
a miércoles volando no tuve ninguna
afección en general lo que pude apreciar
es
normal
distinto con nieve tormenta
pero hasta el momento ha manejado
relativamente bien riccardo rápida
rápidamente para finalizar nuestra
conversación cuál es una posible
solución y le pregunto si nosotros como
usuarios como viajeros deberíamos
preocuparnos por esto de industria la
principal preocupación de la industria y
la seguridad y en ese sentido las líneas
aéreas como los fabricantes los
proveedores van a trabajar rápidamente
en buscar una solución a este tema
precisamente porque la aviación insecto
con equipos de que no funcionen aunque
sean afectados no es sostenible entonces
es fundamental que la industria aérea va
a trabajar en conjunto y probablemente
acelere y acelere
en la marcha o el respecto como la
tecnología sin cómo incorporar la
tecnología
comprobar que los equipos que
actualmente están las aeronaves no van a
ser afectados entonces va a ser un
período de estudios quizás problemas
lente que acelere pero hay que dar la
tranquilidad que la industria pusiera en
base a la seguridad y en ese sentido las
compañías aéreas como los proveedores
para auxiliar o la óptica para trabajar
a favor de ellos van a bajar sobre la
marcha totalmente de acuerdo para
trabajar muy encima con la presión que
van a tener pero
en este momento este margen en seis
meses debiera dar un espacio de para
trabajar en conjunto para avanzar en
superar este desafío
14 y 26 minutos
riccardo gracias por su tiempo por estar
conversando sobre lo que ocurre en eeuu
con esta red 5g y el conflicto que
podría tener entonces con la aviación
estadounidense ricardo gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa